why would i need a license for something
that i've been doing all of my life i
began to feel like a criminal i'm
breaking the law
hi i'm nick gillespie with reason tv and
we're at freedom fest 2014 in las vegas
we're talking with melanie armstrong
she's a cosmotologist based in tupelo
mississippi and she is the subject of a
great new documentary from honest
enterprise tv which is headed up by sean
malone thanks guys uh sean let me start
with you what uh tell us a little bit
about honest enterprise tv and how
melanie's story fits into it honest
enterprise tv is a platform that i built
through the charles koch institute
where um it's basically just a
documentary platform we tell the stories
of
entrepreneurs from around the country
and the struggles that they've faced
either within
state and federal
regulatory bureaucracies and legislative
issues and all the kinds of things that
people really don't think about a whole
lot when they think about small business
so all the challenges melanie talk a
little bit about tell us your business
and then what was the the main hassle
that you had and just you know putting
people to work and giving customers what
they wanted well i all naturally
speaking natural hair care salon and
braiding braiding the natural hair care
salon we opened in 1999.
well shortly after that i wanted to
expand my business and train other young
women to come in and be able to braid
alongside with me and they were unable
to do that without obtaining a full 1500
hour cosmetology license themselves so
and i mean talk a little bit i mean you
got to pay a fee for a cosmetology
license and then you've got to take
about a bunch of coursework is this
something that was i mean the state says
you have to do this otherwise you're in
trouble right
absolutely prior to 2005 it was law that
you had to have a 1500 hour cosmetology
license which um
back then was about ten thousand dollars
of course now it's increased
significantly yeah so uh uh continue so
what did you do yeah i mean you run a
you know into the long arm of the law
and then what do you do to adjust or to
address the situation well what we had
to do
i joined with the institute for justice
and we began lobbying to get
that law passed
and we were able to do that we had to
you know convince
our state representatives that this is
nothing that's going to be harmful we
don't need to be regulated all i'm
trying to do is grow my business and so
after
you know just our just countless efforts
and traveling back and forth to jackson
and speaking with the state
representatives we were successful in
getting the law passed where do you
think the urge to regulate hair braiding
comes from i mean and you know is it is
it because it's something that maybe you
know like some legislators have no
experience with is it that they just see
it as a place of you know a way of
getting more money is it the existing
cosmetology world says like we went
through this you've got to go through
too i mean where's it coming from i
really don't think that it has anything
to do
with the state legislators i the
decision really comes from the state
board of cosmetology and i believe that
the
out the reason for it is to
control
and you know just to keep it to keep
competition out yeah in the end the
senate chairman even came down pretty
hard on me and i said look it's just
real simple i do not give a damn whether
there's a cosmetology law in the state
of mississippi or not so don't you come
back to my office it is over do you
understand i will not put braiding in
the law and that was the end of it
and so by keeping competition out of it
raises your costs it raises customers
because it raises your employees costs
so thank you uh you know sean uh talk a
little bit about honest enterprise i
mean you focus on on the next project
you focus a lot on occupational
licensing and the barriers to
entrepreneurship what do you got in the
pipeline yeah we've done a lot on
occupational licensing so far i would
also by the way add real quick to uh to
what melanie said that the cosmetology
board also was primarily comprised of
people who ran the cosmetology schools
which got all of the the money from the
licensing classes and all that kind of
stuff so so i mean it's
an incredible conflict of interest
doesn't begin to describe it it's like
you get to create your own cash cow
absolutely i mean there's a lot of
cronyism here and and across the board
and a lot of the stories that honest
enterprise is dedicated to telling i
think you find this kind of thing you
find a lot of cronyism you find a lot of
people who are using the law to keep
people out to retain their own
advantages
and i think that's a that's a really
terrible thing and it's also something
that i think a lot of americans a lot of
people in general just really don't know
that much about because
people work in different industries they
don't think about it it's just something
that doesn't come up the next project
that we actually have on the table and
we're actually starting the editing
process basically right now is a story
about a farmer and it's it's less
occupational licensing more about
land use and property rights and it's
about her right to be able to sell
produce off her farm i want to thank
melanie armstrong good luck with the
business keep it going and thank you for
fighting for you know the rights of
small business people everywhere really
and sean malone at honors enterprise tv
for reason tv i'm nick gillespie